[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour le
début d'une nouvelle saison
d'information locale très heureux de
vous retrouver à la présentation de
cette émission le 7-8 week-end de
l'actualité toujours pour terminer la
semaine mais aussi des idées de sorties
pour bien débuter le week-end dans les
yvelines voici le sommaire
semaine de rentrée scolaire 309 1089
élèves ont fait leur retour en classe
dans les yvelines et une fois encore
c'est en pleine épidémie de kobe de 19
et nouveau protocole campagne de
vaccination dans les collèges et lycées
on vous explique tout dans un instant le
contexte sanitaire avait justement
impacté le tourisme l'année dernière
qu'en est il pour cet effet avec une
météo morose et l'instauration du pass
sanitaire exemple à suivre et invité est
mon de lapanouse élu à la cci versailles
yvelines et olivier big brésil bigot
président du club hôtelier 78 et de quoi
vous occuper pour samedi et dimanche et
le week-end prochain aussi avec une
découverte vous le voyez et des sports
nautiques ce sera également au programme
de cette émission il sera avec moi tout
au long de cette saison pour et bien
vous donner ses idées de sorties dans le
sais tu ce week-end c'est bixente
mayence insisté ban bonjour bixente un
genre paris pour cette nouvelle saison
sur tb 78 en pleine forme on est prêt à
commencer sur les chapeaux de roue et il
ya déjà plein de choses au programme de
ce week-end oui on parlera du festival
des mots ce samedi à bon port la mort y
héberger député des yvelines viendra
nous le présenter en tant que présidente
d'honneur de l'association organisatrice
ce sera tout à l'heure dans le sais tu
ce week-end
mais place d'abord à l'actualité 12
millions d'élèves ont fait leur rentrée
ce jeudi 2 septembre en france c'est
l'ouverture d'une autre année scolaire
particulière sous le signe du coc vie de
19 avec en toile de fond la vaccination
pourtant le retour en classe suscite
moins d'inquiétude que la rentrée
précédente comme l'ont constaté dans les
yvelines justin brasier et antoine
durant près de trois cent dix mille
yvelinois ont repris le chemin de
l'école ce jeudi 2 septembre une
nouvelle rentrée dans un contexte de
crise sanitaire pour les parents pas
d'inquiétude particulière les élèves ont
pris l'habitude pas plus d'inquiétude
voire beaucoup moins que l'an passé les
choses sont bien rodés dans l'école tout
s'est très bien déroulé l'année dernière
les effectivement les masques sont
toujours là mais on a l'impression pour
les enfants ça change pas grand chose un
peu comme l'année dernière pour mon fils
qui passe en cm2 cette année ça s'est
très bien passé comme l'année dernière
même moins stressant parce que du coup
il va là il avait déjà
connu ça l'année dernière les protocoles
sanitaires diffèrent selon les niveaux
dans le premier degré si malgré le
maintien des gestes barrières et les
précautions prises un enfant est porteur
de l'aco vide la classe est fermée
pendant une semaine et dans ces
conditions là le professeur travaillera
à distance avec l'ensemble de la classe
lorsqu'on est au collège ou au lycée
là on procède ce qu'on appelle le
contact racing ce qu'ils ont et donc été
qu'un contact ces élèves là et seulement
ceux là font l'objet d'une éviction mais
parmi ceux-là ciena qui sont
complètement vaccinés ils peuvent
revenir en classe nouveauté de la
rentrée les opérations de vaccination
envers les collégiens et les lycéens
les établissements scolaires ont été
liés à 84 centres objectif mettre en
oeuvre la vaccination selon deux
modalités soient les élèves se déplace
vers le centre de vaccination ce sera la
majorité des cas soit nous ferons venir
des équipes mobiles des centres éphémère
dans les établissements donc tout cela
est prêt et nous sommes prêts à démarrer
dès cette semaine et le début de la
semaine prochaine sur la vaccination
pour leurs 50 % des élèves yvelinois ont
reçu une dose de vaccin 30 % disposent
d'un schéma vaccinal complet du côté des
professeurs la joie bien sûr de
retrouver leurs élèves mais aussi
l'inquiétude en raison du temps scolaire
perdu l'année dernière un appel à la
grève a été lancé pour le jeudi 23
septembre ils demandent plus de moyens
avec notamment est la réunion d'un
collectif budgétaire pour mettre en
place des moyens d'urgence les propos
sont relayés par justine braz et il aura
fallut même temps de kovy de créer des
postes il y en a poursuivi la politique
de suppressions de postes et nous ce
qu'on aurait souhaité évidemment c'est
qui est aussi un collectif budgétaire
qu'ils soient réunies pour qu'on crée
des moyens exceptionnels pour pour faire
face aux conséquences de la crise
sanitaire puisque cette année nous
accueillons dans les établissements les
élèves qui ont deux années scolaires
fortement impacté par l'épidémie est la
rentrée c'est aussi l'occasion pour nous
de regarder ce qu'il s'est passé durant
l'été en matière de tourisme juin mais
surtout et juillet et août ont été
marqués par une météo morose sans
oublier l'instauration du pass sanitaire
quel impact sur le secteur dans le
département avec mon plateau deux
invités dont de la panoz bonjour bonjour
vous êtes élu à la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie versailles yvelines
également propriétaire du zoo safari et
du château de thoiry également olivier
bigot qui est avec nous bonjour bonjour
que vous êtes vous le président du club
hôtelier 78 alors je vous propose avant
de démarrer la discussion est de prendre
la température dans ce reportage de
mélanie poquet qui est allé interroger
quelques sites yvelinois une population
plus local plus yvelinoise après deux
mois d'été l'heure est au bilan le
tourisme notent une amélioration par
rapport à 2020 environ 20% pour
l'hôtellerie notamment selon le
département sur l'international on est
plutôt sur la hollande la belgique
l'allemagne mais c'est vrai que les
grands touristes qui viennent par
exemple à paris qui ensuite se déverse
sur notre département cette année
n'était pas là donc au niveau de
l'hôtellerie c'est un vrai sujet plus de
dix mille visiteurs de moins du côté de
france miniature sur le mois de juillet
si les trois premières semaines de
vacances était conforme aux attentes des
équipes les trois suivantes ont vu
l'instauration du passé ni terre le 21
juillet freiné la venue du public nos
visiteurs sont des familles avec enfants
et tous n'étaient pas encore dans un
schéma vaccinal complet donc la première
partie en tout cas compter du 21 juillet
a été elle plus difficile et ça pendant
quinze jours trois semaines le temps que
que le parcours vaccinale soit complet
et apprenaient revenue sur la dernière
partie
des chiffres en deux ça aussi pour lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
la fréquentation a baissé de 25% en
juillet et de 20 % en août c'est
vraiment la météo qui est le facteur
prédominant au niveau des activités en
plus souffert
notamment tout ce qui est activités du
père promenade donc les vélos
quoi de karting électrique rosalie les
manèges la buvette là c'est typiquement
familial on y vient sans réservation et
ont dix ans lorsque lorsqu'on se
réveille ben voilà le soleil est là et
là le sol n'était pas là donc elles ont
subi vraiment de plein fouet ces pros la
météo en 2020 l'été avait été synonyme
d'une baisse de fréquentation de 70%
pour les différents sites touristiques
yvelinois 2021 serait légèrement
meilleure plus d'un tiers des
professionnels estimerait que leur
fréquentation est en hausse on l'a
compris peut-être une légère embellie
même si le bilan reste très contrastée
dans les yvelines est ce que c'est le
constat aussi général que vous dressez
aujourd'hui elles m'ont de lapanouse
globalement sur l'été il faut compter
que les cytises au mont perdu 10 15%
certains il ya une bonne nouvelle c'est
d'un pierre qui sont tout neufs et ils
ont continué leur progression et ça je
suis très heureux pour eux mais touahri
ses traits c'est quand même dingue
laulan bien maintenue avec un petit
creux sur près d'une semaine ou deux le
temps de mettre en place des centres de
vaccination pour le niveau sanitaire des
sites certains sites ont certains
châteaux ont comme bretagne ont pu faire
face au passé ni terme et
et ont pu se maintenir d'autres
d'autres ont un peu subi il ya quand
même une baisse globale ce qui est
important vraiment retenir c'est que les
entreprises et tous les châteaux serait
le château les monuments les musées eux
on est un peu souffert de cette mise en
place c'est compliqué pour des bâtiments
pour tout ce qui est lié au fait remuer
il est clairement un effet pas sanitaire
en plus de la météo qui est venu
s'ajouter aussi amoureuse mais tout ce
qui est en extérieur que ce soit les des
sitcoms comme l'espace rambouillet
france miniature touahri ça la bergerie
tout ce qui était en extérieur ça un peu
plus et ça a un peu aidés et ça a un peu
aidés mais dans ces séances chaque site
ah c'est un peu fait face de manière
différente en fonction des moyens qu'ils
avaient et aussi des installations
facile quand vous un centre de
vaccination sur place n'est sûr que
quand vous n'avez pas pour pourrait
trouver au puy ils s'inquiètent aussi à
un moment de latence moment
l'instauration les gens ne savaient pas
s'il était obligatoire sur certains
sites etc ça peut être aussi un rôle de
fou ça c'est sûr et puis surtout mais ce
qui a fait plus plus pâle dirais c'est
la météo on a quand même un été qui
était frais dans le nord de la france et
un public adoré des touristes français
qui sont restés en france mais qui sont
allés vraiment sur les côtes et on l'a
vu donc sa moitié sud en a profité tant
mieux pour eux nous nos métiers nord
c'est sûr du pays on a beaucoup sur ce
côté là et puis très peu de touristes
étrangers ça c'est sûr ça fait mal pour
plus pour le tourisme culturel
principal olivier rigaud du côté des
hôteliers aussi même constat il ya eu
vraiment en effet pas sanitaire est en
effet météo aussi dans les yeux il n'y a
pas forcément l'effet passe sanitaire a
la base je dirais que je suis beaucoup
plus contrasté que dans le reportage
dont parle scandalise 20% et le rapport
à l'année dernière elle n'est pas réel
par rapport à l'année dernière oui il ya
une embellie mais d'abord elle est rien
en mesure par rapport à 2019 on est
plutôt sur des -50% de manière générale
que ce soit juin juillet août chez pas
les statistiques de l'ine in extenso
pardon en ce qui concerne je dirais des
statistiques plus local des membres dont
2 mai hôtels ont été au delà de voyager
pour prétendre pour cent des membres qui
ont répondu à ma statistique récente sur
juin juillet août et alors il ya de très
grands contrastes il ya des hôtels qui
ont fait je dirais la même chose que
l'année dernière et voire mieux que en
2019 ça dépend du positionnement le
moyenne gamme a moins souffert le plus
haut de gamme a été très impacté le
reste encore pourquoi la segmentation
clientèle internationale
a un impact réel et là on est encore sur
des chiffres dramatiques quant aux
passes sanitaires bien sûr que c'était
un enjeu supplémentaire
pour la restauration puisque évidemment
beaucoup d'hôtels ont une offre de
services de restauration et c'est une
difficulté supplémentaire à mettre en
oeuvre et parfois à frein pour les
clients plus du coup une fois ce constat
dressé les perspectives alors je précise
que vous allez être le directeur général
d'un établissement qui va ouvrir à jouy
en josas très très prochainement les
perspectives pour les hôteliers
tel est le voilà l'état d'esprit
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est plutôt
l'inquiétude sur les prochaines semaines
qui vont arriver si on reste toujours
inquiet et mais néanmoins mobiliser et
motiver à faire la promotion de la
destination ou telle destination
notamment des yvelines bien sûr
il ya un petit peu de séminaires donc là
évidemment on est plus sur la partie
estivale je dirais vacances mais il ya
des séminaires des petits séminaires qui
s'organise donc là il ya une réelle
demande et tant mieux ça donne déjà un
peu de d'activité et puis du court
séjour les franciliens adore
la verdure donc on a quand même un atout
majeur dans les yvelines on a beaucoup
de l'espace extérieur comme comme le
disait non mais en l'occurrence les
hôtels sont aussi situés dans des
espaces plutôt bucolique et ça
s'appelait les parisiens les fronts
sillage des raisons le sens plus large m
aussi sur des destinations qui ont une
offre alors plus complète
typiquement ci est ce pas un bon
restaurant ça fonctionne le mot de la
fin en 30 secondes et demande la panouse
vous souhaitiez passer un appel un sur
eux sur ce plateau oui j'invite les
foncières et particulièrement ceux
visant des habitants des yvelines à se
tourner vers a déjà leurs commerces et
les artisans de leur ville parce qu'ils
en ont besoin aussi un sortie de crise
ou pas les oublier on a monté un club
escale pays pour eux je les croisières
et qui pourrait inciter aussi les
touristes étrangers quand ils vont venir
de les découvrir il voit la chambre de
commerce et la dernière chose que le
dire je fais invite aussi à aller sur le
site passe malin.fr il y à 67 sites
tous ici que culturelles et de loisirs
qui participent à cette opération entre
les yvelines et les hauts de seine allez
visiter les sites de proximité c'est le
meilleur moyen de les soutenir ils sont
là pour vous ils font plein d'événements
regarder les éléments qu'il faut plein
d'événements originaux et vous avez une
litote des offres comme ça qui sont
valables toute l'année le message est
passé merci à vous deux noms de la panoz
olivier d'ego d'être venu nous livrer
ses premières tendances sur le tourisme
estival sur le plateau de tv 78 l'été
2021 finit donc presque mais pas encore
un n'oublions pas que il se terminera
officiellement à l'été le 22 septembre
prochain alors pour les chanceux qui ont
été loin des yvelines et qui auraient
manqué les événements marquants de
juillet et août petit rappel avec célia
garçons go était 2021 particulier dans
les yvelines avec l'instauration du pass
sanitaires depuis le 21 juillet il est
obligatoire pour accéder aux lieux de
loisirs et de culture comme les musées
cinémas
ces derniers ont vu une chute de la
fréquentation de 70% il est aussi
indispensable depuis le 9 août pour
aller manger au restaurant sont et suivi
des centres commerciaux pas sanitaire
exigé lundi 23 août dans 14 centres
commerciaux des yvelines pour être
finalement suspendu deux jours après par
le tribunal administratif de versailles
l'été yvelinois 2021 a été marquée aussi
par le sport ils sont revenus sourire
aux lèvres et médailles au cou les onze
athlètes yvelinois ont brillé lors des
jeux olympiques de tokyo qui se
déroulait du 23 juillet au 8 août un peu
plus de six médailles remportées comme
au triathlon avec trois représentants du
club de poissy qui ont obtenu la
médaille de bronze par équipes mixtes en
équitation même couleur de médailles
pour christopher 6 qui finit troisième
en concours complet par équipes des
yvelinois reviennent aussi avec deux
médailles d'or handball pour le
versailles et valentin porte et en judo
par équipes mixtes guillaume chaîne du
club de sartrouville
ils étaient nombreux à venir applaudir
tad edge paugaite chars double vainqueur
du tour ou encore le champion du monde
julian alaphilippe la dernière étape du
tour de france s'élance et à chatou le
18 juillet c'est la quatrième année
consécutive que la grande boucle
s'élance des yvelines côté politique le
conseil d'état a enfin tranché
l'élection municipale à trappes a été
annulé mi août le feuilleton judiciaire
qui opposait le maire de trappes à lire
à b et son opposant au conseil municipal
othman menace roux a pris fin avira b a
été sanctionné par ses actions de
propagande qui ont faussé le verdict des
urnes de nouvelles élections se
tiendront les 10 et 17 octobre 2021 en
nouveau duel s'annonce entre les deux
rivaux valérie pécresse a annoncé jeudi
22 juillet sa candidature pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
elle venait tout juste d'être réélu pour
un second mandat à la présidence de la
région ile de france son programme sera
basé sur la volonté de restaurer la
fierté française elle souhaite
participer à la primaire de la droite
c'est un chantier d'envergure qui débute
attrape le pont marcel cachin a été
démoli dans la nuit du 17 au 18 août il
surplombe et la route nationale 10 au
niveau de la mairie de la ville c'est
une première étape pour ce chantier de
six ans l'enfouissement de la nationale
10 menée par la direction des routes
d'île de france et pour terminer ça a
été pour lui son plus bel été le chef
erwan restaurateur à bourdonner un
village yvelinois de 500 habitants a vu
les clients affluer dans son restaurant
grâce à une blogueuse qui a recommandé
sa cuisine et une vidéo vue plus de 37
millions de fois le chef est devenu
célèbre et fait salle pleine midi et
soir
et maintenant le retour de biche et les
imériens senti steban qui je le sais et
paraît à vous donner l'envié de sortir
ce week-end dans les yvelines beaucoup
de possibilités bixente en effet comme
nous le disions tout à l'heure ce samedi
4 septembre c'est le festival des mots à
montfort l'amaury une journée entière
consacrée aux métiers du livre au
programme des conférences données par
des professionnels des rencontres et des
ateliers pour nous en parler aurore
bergé et valérie valette de
l'association les amis du sud yvelines
sont avec nous bonjour
vous êtes les prés de la présidente est
la présidente d'honneur de l'association
les amis du sud divine alix est à
l'initiative de l'événement quel est
l'objectif de cette journée c'est de
finalement c'est de mettre à l'honneur
le monde du livre dans son intégralité
oui et la culture également promouvoir
montré que dans le territoire sous
divine il y a énormément de talent que
ce soit sur le plan littéraire que sur
le plan
et puis une année aussi on a été quand
même beaucoup séparés les uns des autres
privé de ce lien direct avec les
artistes est ici dans le sud des
yvelines on est au château de grousset
on accueillera le public demain à
montfort l'amaury et on a la chance
d'avoir des auteurs des artistes des
sculpteurs des troupes aussi des
compagnies artistiques et donc on les
met à l'honneur demain c'est un
événement qui est gratuit et ouvert à
tous les publics et comme je le disais
une bonne partie de la journée sera
consacrée aux conférences autour du
livre son histoire son utilité quels
seront les sujets abordés
alors nous allons parler de l'album
jeunesse entre autres un et du rôle de
l'image
dans l'album et en littérature jeunesse
en fait c'est l'idée c'est de partir de
tout le parcours du livre donc on part
de l'idée de sa conception de son
illustration y compris avec celles et
ceux qui le façonne au sens propre du
terme avec des relieurs avec des
typographes qu'ils vont montrer aussi
quelles sont leurs métiers et des
métiers qui potentiellement pourrait
parfois disparaître s'efface et puis
avec des éditeurs des libraires des
bibliothécaires des auteurs des
illustrateurs n'a vraiment essayé de
réunir tous les métiers qui gravitent
autour du livre et en faisant vraiment
la part belle à celles et ceux qui sont
sur le territoire des yvelines du sud
yvelines avec par exemple si un
partenariat que la maison jean monnet
qui est juste à côté à bazoches sur
guyonne et avec des intervenants qui
nous viennent du luxembourg un petit peu
plus loin que les yvelines et qui
viendront parler de la place du livre au
sein de l'europe tout simplement et
commença sa façade l'europe et en même
temps on souhaite mettre en lumière le
réseau au fil des pages qui est un
réseau de médiathèques sur le territoire
sud yvelines qui ont expliqué à la fois
de professionnels et de bénévoles c'est
aussi un peu rendre hommage au travail
qui est fait tout autour de la lecture
et du livre et en deux mots rapides dans
la journée se terminera par une pièce de
théâtre c'est ça exactement parce
qu'elle se trouve en plus qu'en 2022 eh
bien ce sera l'anniversaire molière
puisque ça fera quatre cents ans que
molière nous aura quitté et donc on va
clôturer parce que les mots c'est aussi
les mots qu'on met en scène et donc
c'est la troupe de théâtre théâtre et
sarabande qui viendra clôturer à 19
heures avec une pièce qui s'appelle et
molière dans tout ça merci or berger et
valérie valette d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle donc un festival des mots se
tiendra demain samedi 4 septembre de
9h30 à 20h une journée entière consacrée
aux livres et ses métiers
et à présent bixente pour les passionnés
de 7e 1 on va continuer déroulé le
programme des activités à faire dans le
week-end les yvelines font leur cinéma
c'est bientôt la fin et autrement dit
c'est se faire une toile à la belle
étoile dans les yvelines font leur
cinéma oui c'est ça grégory c'était
l'une des animations du département et
des communes des yvelines tout au long
du mois d'août ça continue en septembre
avec encore 12 séances en plein air
prévues ce mardi 7 septembre par exemple
vous pourrez revoir un classique du
cinéma français à clairefontaine en
yvelines astérix et obélix contre césar
[Applaudissements]
et grégory si je vous dis j'ai glissé
chef ça vous fait penser à quoi je sèche
mais c'est un film assez anciens quand
même hein je pense oui exactement c'est
la 7ème compagnie ce sera l'un des trois
derniers films diffusés pour la joute
dernière rejoindre l'événement vendredi
prochain le 10 septembre toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
site yves hinse irait info.fr et pour
compléter le programme di centa un
classique en cette rentrée il est
important pour nous parce qu'on pratique
des activités sportives dans un club
c'est les traditionnel forum des
associations en effet ça se déroule ce
week-end au le week-end prochain celui
du 10 septembre selon les communes comme
chaque année c'est l'occasion de
découvrir ou de vous réinscrire à de
nombreuses activités pour l'année qui
débute pour connaître la date et les
programmes de vos communes rendez vous
sur les sites internet de vos mairies
weetjens aussi l'occasion de s'essayer à
de nouveaux sports pourquoi pas de
nouvelles pratiques bixente de découvrir
ces pratiques les sports nautiques par
exemple avec un terrain de jeu sur la
scène d'ailleurs grégory vous êtes
essayé au wakeboard et au wake surf du
côté de villennes sur seine et si on
regardait le reportage
[Musique]
vivre une expérience de glisse
directement à proximité pari impossible
vous me direz bien si c'est possible ici
à villennes-sur-seine club week-end
glisse vous accueille au sein de sa base
nautique pour des activités et on en
parle avec son gérant alexis née clauss
bonjour alexis bonjour déjà ici on est
dans un cadre un peu exceptionnelle on
peut le dire c'est la scène qui nous
permet de faire ses activités ce qui est
exactement tout à fait mais très proche
de paris on est à vingt minutes donc on
est directement sur la scène on est sur
un petit bras mort vous voyez le bateau
qui est là qui nous sert à faire le 10
sport nautique c'est destiné
exclusivement à sa éventuellement des
petites balades et on peut pratiquer
tous les sports nautiques tracts et on
va essayer de sport aujourd'hui deux
pratiques wakeboard ou ex heures vous
allez la différence entre les deux voilà
donc deux sports tractés voilà vous avez
par exemple une planche de wakeboard
c'est encore assez connu on est proche
du ski nautique donc on est tirée par le
par le bateau avec le palonnier des
chaussées directement sur la planche
voilà donc après le principe c'est de
sortir de l'eau de rester tractée par le
bateau de faire des figures sur la vague
donc ça c'est pour le wakeboard le
whizzer sutton excès enfin peu différent
la pratique un peu près la même bon
on sort toujours avec une corde en main
eux
quand beaucoup plus courte on est à peu
près là 3-4 mètres du bateau on tire
beaucoup moins vite et le principe
ensuite donc là vous avez vu pas de
choses pas de chasse aux pieds donc on
met directement les
les pieds sur la planche on se rapproche
du surf traditionnelle qu'on connaît en
mer tout le monde peut en faire et ce
que même si on est débutant peut
s'initier avec n'a fait ça commence à
partir de 7-8 ans sur du c'ur du
wakeboard wagstaff c'est un peu plus
compliqué ski nautique on peut commencer
encore un peu plus jeunes 6 7 ans et
apprécié destiné à tout le monde bien
sûr c'est parti pour test
[Musique]
c'est parti pour l'embarquement sur le
bateau qui va me tracter durant les
activités notre terrain de jeu
aujourd'hui la scène bien sûr au niveau
de l'ancien pont de poissy et comme
c'est une première pour moi une certaine
forme d'appréhension se lit sur mon
visage
[Musique]
je débute avec le wakeboard après m'être
équipe et j'écoute avec attention les
conseils de julien et puis c'est la mise
à l'eau
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que les débuts sont laborieux
[Musique]
m
au bout de la neuvième tentative
j'arrive enfin à sortir de l'eau et à
tenir sur la planche une poignée de
secondes la fatigue se fait ressentir il
est temps de faire une pause et
d'observer
[Musique]
bien leur ensuite d'essayer le wakesurf
cette fois ci les pieds ne sont pas
attachés à la planche le premier essai
est ratée puis miracle enfin une
tentative réussie j'ai réussi à tenir
debout une minute
[Musique]
et ça y est je viens de terminer ma
session est justement avec moi il ya
julien mais qui est gérant associé qui
m'a un peu guidée dans cette initiation
comment tu m'as trouvé julien pour un
début c'est jamais trop évident mais
est bien sorti et a réussi à
sortir en vrac surf donc c'est déjà pas
mal en général a toujours 10 15 minutes
assez complexe au début mais là de la
session suivante à mon avis tu seras
debout et puis tu pourras déjà bien
amusé surfer la vague est donc là j'ai
essayé le wakesurf le wakeboard il ya
d'autres activités qui sont proposées
par week-end glisse ouais donc on peut
aussi faire du foil du ski nautique du
mono et puis après on a aussi les sports
à peu près tranquille du type paddle
histoire se balader sur les sur les
canaux un peu plus tranquillement quoi
et donc pour les activités que j'ai
testé pour une initiation de 15 minutes
comptait une quarantaine d'euros une
cession au groupe d'une heure 150 euros
et les activités ici à cette base
nautique de villennes sur seine sont
ouvertes jusqu'à fin novembre un bel
exemple d'apprentissage du wakeboard un
gregorio fait d'ailleurs je crois qu'on
a un petit ralenti sur votre technique
est ce qu'on peut revoir ça alesi a les
yeux on va regarder ça oui j'arrive à
maintenir mais je m'écroule tout de
suite au plongeon je suis gardien de but
donc j'ai la technique et églises et
déjà mais ça va ça pas fait trop mal je
rassure les téléspectateurs qui veulent
s'y essayer n'hésitez pas et d'ailleurs
je salue alex et julien c'est une équipe
très sympathique qu'on a rencontrés avec
vous bixente aussi avec michael et demi
d'euros qui étaient là pour ce reportage
alors on va refermer cette émission avec
une nouveauté vous avez parlé des idées
de sorties de ce week-end on va se
projeter aussi monté dans votre machine
temporelle pour le week-end prochain
pour voir ce qu'il se passe aussi pour
les week-ends le week end du 11 et 12
septembre oui dans le même registre que
les yvelines font leur cinéma les opéras
d'été auront lieu chaque samedi de
septembre des projections de balai au
clair de lune sur un transat seront
proposés
c'est tout à fait gratuit on essaie de
faire des repérages sur des lieux en
plein air alors cette année on n'a pas
été forcément gâté cet été mais là comme
il fait beau aujourd'hui on se dit que
sur septembre puisque ça démarre le 4 eh
bien on aura du beau temps et qu'on
pourra dans en plein air et bien avoir
des écrans géants pour pouvoir et bien
voir des oeuvres intéressantes
passionnante et des oeuvres connues
quand même dans dans l'ensemble trois
oeuvres incontournables seront diffusés
le songe d'une nuit d'été le barbier de
séville et les indes galantes 12 villes
ont été choisies pour couvrir les quatre
week-ends de septembre rendez vous donc
dès ce samedi 4 septembre bréviaire à
orgeval et or sont ville début des
projections dès que le soleil se couche
prévoyez donc une petite laine pour
finir la ferme du manet qui comme moi
cette année fête ses 30 ans exactement
galerie pendant tout le week-end des 10
11 et 12 septembre donc du vendredi au
dimanche marché du terroir animations
concerts et skins game et j'en passe de
nombreuses activités seront à découvrir
pendant voilà c'est à découvrir à tout
plein sur sur ce site de la ferme du
mana qui je le rappelle fête ses 30 ans
le merci bixente et c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission se retrouvent vendredi
prochain pour une nouvelle émission une
deuxième oui on enchaîne dès vendredi
prochain ici sur le plateau tv ça
s'embrasse peut être rodés à l'exercice
et vous préciser aussi un qui à leur
tour de vos éditions locales du journal
1 à partir de lundi lundi au jeudi à 18
heures pour connaître à tous de
l'actualité locale yvelinoise d'ici là à
passer un excellent week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
tous